genau wie gesagt ich herzlichen dank
erstmal für die für die einladung
herzlichen dank für diese organisation
von dem tollen symposium und wenn man
jetzt die ersten vorträge gehört hat und
jetzt nochmal die die liste an der
kommenden vorträge und dann bin ich mir
ganz sicher dass wir morgen abend hier
mit vielen neuen ideen rauskommen und
auch ganz enthusiastisch sind und und
vielleicht auch neue kooperationspartner
für die umsetzung der eigenen leer
projekte finden werden
genau das hat eben schon gesagt ich
leite eine arbeitsgruppe in der
medizinischen fakultät und wir arbeiten
an der klinischen klinischen
grundlagenforschung und wenn ich ganz
ehrlich bin füllt mich das total aus und
klar mache ich lehre aber eigentlich
habe ich dafür wie der lask ist vorhin
gesagt hat fehlt mir einfach wirklich
die zeit aber natürlich genauso wie sie
wäre ich auch nicht hier wenn mit
lehrern es irgendwie spaß machen würde
und deswegen habe ich für mich nach
einem format gesucht wie ich lehre
machen kann die mir spaß macht die
relativ wenig aufwand hat und die den
studenten auch irgendwas bringt und da
bin ich eben auf dem phillip glass sturm
gekommen und ich habe das den vortrag
jetzt extra sogenannt einstieg in philip
glass um verwahrte leicht gemacht denn
ich weiß man kann das auf ganz
verschiedenen ebenen relativ kompliziert
und wahnsinnig perfekt machen
das ist jetzt die absolute abgespeckte
version und die frage kommen frei zum
zeitmanagement die relativ wenig zeit
gekostet hat klipp klar sturm oder auch
inverted glaskunst vielleicht gerade
schlecht aus machen dann wird es ein
bisschen besser wahrscheinlich ist
glaube ich ein konzept das muss ich hier
nicht unbedingt vorstellen werde ich nun
mal ganz ganz kurz noch mal noch mal
beschreiben das ist das und klassische
konzept wie eine vorlesung mit dem
frontalunterricht gehalten wird dass es
so wie allein stemmen muss man
vielleicht manchmal machen aber richtig
spaß macht es auch nicht und was der
flip oder inverted klasse macht ist dass
er diese
die hier im frontalunterricht geschieht
einfach umdreht flippt ja das heißt die
wissensvermittlung findet nicht mehr im
frontalunterricht stadt in
zusammenarbeit mit den studenten sondern
die findet in einer anderen phase statt
die der student eben alleine machen kann
und das kann ich gleich vorweg geben
er spart mir unheimlich viel zeit die
ich dann habt wenn ich dann wieder mit
den studenten im klassenraum oder
zusammen bin die ich dann habe um mit
den studenten wirklich die interessanten
dinge die ich vermitteln möchte zu
diskutieren ein großes und genau hier
ist also ein bisschen zusammen reißt die
klassische vorstellung den input kriegt
die studenten in der vorlesung die
aktivität die kinder nach hause arbeiten
das nach gehen da vielleicht noch ein
bisschen tiefer in die eine oder andere
richtung die sie interessiert und
bereiten sich vor allem auf die klausur
vor die sie dann schreiben und dann
hoffentlich mit bravour bestehen
das ist die klassische vorlesung und
beim club glasform ist es eben so dass
der hauptsächlich input der
informationsfluss vor der face to face
phase statt findet der student entweder
alleine zu hause oder sogar in
gruppenarbeit bereitet sich auf das
thema vor
und das gibt eben viel zeit mit dem
dozenten in der face to face time also
in der zeit wo wir den studenten sehen
einfach tiefer einzugehen in diese
thematik oder eben auch den transfer von
wissen zu zu leisten
ein ganz großer grund warum für mich
persönlich flippt classroom wirklich ein
gutes modell ist ist das und wo ich auch
zum ersten mal durch umgesetzt hat das
ist eine vorlesung im modul des
masterstudiengangs also ganz klar ich
arbeite mit master studenten die sind
relativ relativ schlau schon
und die sind natürlich auch relativ die
diverse haben sie welche die haben sich
so das studium durchgemogelt oder gibts
dann entweder die die die schlaumeier
diddy diddy alles wirklich sehr sehr gut
und intensiv wissen
das heißt dass masterstudiengang und der
heißt die biologie der tu mal entstehung
da gibt es eigentlich einfach darum ob
emi entsteht und welche zelle und welche
signale sind dafür notwendig
und in dieser vorlesung so sind in der
regel so je nach semester 50 bis 70
leute habe ich eben unterschiedliche
leute ich habe einmal studenten der
biologie und dann habe ich den hier der
ganz normales wissen hat und ich habe
mir den schlaumeier ja dann habe ich
gleichzeitig studenten der biochemie und
studenten der molekulare biologie
biotechnologie
das sind 3 also recht verwandte
studiengänge aber trotzdem haben die in
ihrer bachelor studiengang komplett
andere vorlesung gehabt das heißt die
haben einfach ein anderes vorwissen von
der information her und dann auch wenn
ich mir praktisch soll ich mal einen gut
ausgebildeten studenten und dann dann
sag ich mal exzellent ausgebildeten den
anschlag auch ein anderes niveau
das heißt die diversität in der
vorlesung ist relativ hoch
und jetzt kann ich natürlich sagen das
ist mir jetzt egal ich ziehe jetzt mal
ein stoff dadurch und ich schaue dass
ich hier irgendwo die mitte treffe die
meisten werden dann schon irgendwie mit
kommen und die anderen müssen sich
danach nachbar nacharbeiten
aber das ist natürlich eine sache die
dann wirklich nicht funktioniert weil
ich da einfach viele studenten unterwegs
verliere das heißt was ich bislang bevor
ich in world class und first-class
formate gemacht habe gemacht habe ist
dass ich in dem ersten teil der
vorlesung die studenten alle auf ein
level gebracht habt ja damit ich da
niemanden abhänge und ich habe bindet
und kommunen situation dass die
vorlesung anderthalb oder auch zwei
stunden gehen kann aber trotzdem je nach
niveau und je nach vorwissen kann das
relativ lange dauern
dauert das manchmal auch eine halbe
stunde muss ich erst mit denen aufklären
der von dem thema gerade überhaupt gar
keine ahnung war es der andere das ist
vielleicht ein bisschen interessiert und
vor allen dingen der schlaumeier der der
der anwalt sich die ganze zeit und und
das kann sein dass ich den vielleicht in
der vorlesung ganz schwer wieder
einfangen kann und das ist einmal ein
punkt der macht keinen spaß weil man
sieht ja entweder in diese fragezeichen
gesicht oder man sieht die leute die
irgendwas anderes machen und und
ja sich nicht nicht wirklich beteiligen
und auf der anderen seite was ich vorhin
schon gesagt habe koste sind immense
zeit und das ist eigentlich zeit die ich
ganz gerne mit den studenten für was
anderes verwenden möchte und deswegen
ist für mich das führt glaswände
perfekte lösung gewesen denn was ich
gemacht habe ist dieses ein level was
ich vorher eine halbe stunde vor der
vorlesung gemacht habe also dieses
dieses aktivieren reaktivieren von
vorwissen nach dem abi web prinzip das
habe ich in eine online phase gepackt
das heißt in dieser online phase haben
sich die studenten entweder alleine am
computer oder ebenen gruppen ein
gewisses vorwissen angeeignet und dieses
vorwissen war auch ganz klar
kommuniziert wird nicht mehr in der
vorlesung wiederholt das heißt dieses
vorwissen ist grundvoraussetzung für
dann die präsenzphase wo wir dann dieses
basiswissen nehmen das weiter vertiefen
und das entweder im frontalunterricht in
dem ich dann noch mal ein bisschen
tiefer in diese materie einsteigt oder
in dem wir zusammen diskutieren und ein
transfer von wissen machen ja dann
transfer von wissen das wissen wir alle
das ist eigentlich die das was wirklich
dann ins langzeitgedächtnis der stunden
studenten geht gut so viel zur theorie
relativ einfach jetzt die frage wie habe
ich das umgesetzt um gesagt ich habe
jetzt hier tatsächlich mit der
modeplattform gearbeitet auch wenn sie
manchmal ein bisschen unübersichtlich
ist da sieht man schon gleich hab's
versucht für die studenten relativ
übersichtlich zu machen das ist jetzt
hier ein komplettes semester mit
verschiedenen themen und ich habe
angefangen indem es den ersten klassen
gemacht dann habe ich noch mal ein thema
nimmt thema und genese als clip trust
classroom gemacht und das können die
studenten hier in verschiedenen reitern
einfach anwählen und sehen dann schon
gleich das dass sie im prinzip bevor die
präsenz veranstaltung stattfindet es
hier etwas gibt was sie abarbeiten
müssen abarbeiten heißt ich habe einmal
eine vorlesung gemacht da habe ich ein
video selber gemacht und habe
gleichzeitig noch weitere informationen
weitergegeben und habe das ganze
hinterher noch mal von den studenten
selbst überprüfen lassen und auf die
anderen themen gehe ich gleich noch ein
ganz wichtig ist dass gerade gerade bei
wenn die studenten sich das selber
aneignen müssen dass man den studenten
relativ genaue vorschriften gibt
letztlich mensch mach das bitte in deren
der reihenfolge und das habe ich jetzt
hier auch so gemacht dass ich also genau
beschrieben habe wenn du darauf klicks
tja das ist ein mp4 format das öffnet
sich automatisch und bitte geh erst die
vorlesung durch und dann macht die
anderen sachen ja also ganz wichtig dass
man die studenten echt an der hand nimmt
und es strukturiert mit denen durchgeht
die herstellung des lehr videos das ist
das was wahrscheinlich am meisten arbeit
gemacht hat oder ab oder am meisten
arbeit machen kann
ich habe es mir da auch relativ einfach
gemacht ich habe eine
powerpoint-präsentation hergestellt aber
natürlich aus verschiedenen falls sie
kennen das alle man hat ja schon
verschiedene power point präsentation
die man irgendwie kombinieren kann und
diese power point präsentation kann man
dann entweder auf einem sehr hohen
niveau und wir haben das glück bei uns
an der tu und medienzentrum zu haben mit
einem studium kann man da im studio und
da kann man das im prinzip aufnehmen mit
einer professionellen ausstattung kriegt
man alles gestellt pc mikrofonständer
videokamera usw und die schneiden das
tatsächlich auch für ein
das ist glaube ich der preis wenn man
das wenn man das mietet von extern für
uns ist ein bisschen günstiger aber ganz
klar da muss ich einen termin mit den
ausmachen den krieg ich vielleicht nicht
morgen wenn mir das gestern abend
eingefallen ist und außerdem bedeutet
rechtzeitig muss in dieses studio gehen
und sind es tatsächlich auch mit kosten
verbunden
das heißt das war so eine sache gesagt
ja das wäre schön das wäre toll wenn ich
perfekt machen wollte aber da habe ich
einfach nicht die zeit dazu ein bisschen
andere version bis die weniger zeit
kostet aber immer noch relativ
semiprofessionell das würde ich sagen
wenn man praktisch die powerpoint
präsentation am startet mit seinem
laptop und dann mit einer video kamera
und einem mikrofon arbeitet und dann
kann man mit einer produktion software
camtasia ist das glaube ich dass was
relativ gut ich habe damit auch schon
mal gearbeitet recht
intuitiv ist ein programm das was kostet
mit dem arbeit ist glaube ich das
medienzentrum an der tu auch ich weiß
gar nicht wie viel das kostet
für mich war das allein schon jedes
programm zu organisieren war schon
eigentlich der relativ viel aufwand und
deswegen habe ich nur noch einfache
lösungen gemacht ich habe einfach mal
eine powerpoint-präsentation gehabt ich
habe mein laptop gehabt ich habe mir
screencast magic runtergeladen und habe
dann einfach die powerpoint präsentation
bei mir auf dem laptop gestartet und
habe den text dazu gesprochen
das heißt im prinzip die ständen ich
habe das jetzt auch das video mal
mitgebracht die studenten sehen die
klassische powerpoint präsentation die
sie vielleicht in der im
frontalunterricht auch sehen würden und
hören eben meine stimme dazu na ja genau
jetzt funktioniert es mit der stimmung
nicht ganz optimal diesen wir also das
ist jetzt relativ einfach irgendwie nur
was ganz kurz erklärt und wenn ich mal
ein bisschen weiter nach hinten
dann sehen sie sehr gut hier zum
beispiel da witten signalweg erklärt
die gewesen
so sehen das ist im prinzip wirklich das
was man im frontalunterricht auch machen
würde manchmal zeigt das leid und die
die studenten hören
im prinzip die stimme dazu und man kann
es eigentlich zu erklären was natürlich
nicht funktioniert ist dass die
studenten irgendwelche zwischenfragen
stellen können ja das ist natürlich das
ist klar
deswegen habe ich auch absichtlich die
das wissen was sich in der online phase
präsentiert hat oder vermitteln wollte
nur das grundwissen gemacht und bin da
nicht so ganz so stark in die in die
tiefe reingegangen aber was eben bei
diesem eigenen lehrvideo absolut positiv
ist ist dass ich wirklich spezifisch auf
die lehrveranstaltung abstimmen kann ja
also ich kann wirklich genau ich kann
auch sagen wie wir vor zwei wochen
besprochen haben oder wie wir in dem
modul so und so besprochen haben
erinnern sie sich darauf beziehe ich
mich jetzt das heißt ich muss nicht mit
irgendwelchen vorgefertigten lehrvideos
arbeiten und kann kann eben den
informationsgehalt ganz ganz explizit
auf meine lehrveranstaltung abstimmen
ganz klar die studenten kennen mich auch
ja die kennen wir kennen meine stimme
die wissen ganz genau wenn die
freilassing hat das so und so sagt dann
ist es echt wichtig ja dann auch solche
solche persönlichen sachen also die
kombination aus bild und stimme die
transportiert einfach emotionen und das
wird immer eigentlich positiv und
studierenden aufgenommen
ganz klar so ein video ist natürlich
auch immer weckt neugier das heißt von
den die studenten haben sich natürlich
alle angeschaut weil sie ja wissen
wollten was er denn da gezeigt wird ja
also das ist auch immer so so dieses
bisschen dass wir
oftmals so gerne fiction nennen die
videosequenz ganz wichtig darf natürlich
nicht zu lang sein in dem fall war sie
glaube ich zehn oder elf minuten lang
und das ist auch was ganz tolles denn
diese kurze videosequenz erleichtert
natürlich den einstieg auch in die in
die arbeitsatmosphäre und dann kriegt
man wissen vermittelt und der eine sagt
dann aber halt moment mit dem und dem
signalmolekül da ist habe ich dann noch
mal was anderes gehört und dann kann er
sich auch hinsetzen kann es in seinem
lehrbuch nachlesen oder kann kann im
internet wie auch nachlesen was ganz
ganz wichtig ist ist dass dieses
lehrvideo beliebig oft wiederholbar ist
und das ist auch ein vorteil zur zur
vorlesung denn wenn wenn dann jetzt dann
irgendwie eine frage hat und man
schreibt was mit und dann vergisst man
sich schon wieder und dann ist der
dozent beim nächsten thema ist es
schwierig hier kann der student das
wirklich zig mal anhören moment habe ich
das richtig verstanden oder muss ich da
irgendwie muss ich mir das nochmal
anhören
und das ist auch dass das ja das mit
einem beliebig oft angehört kann und
auch stoppen kann und sagen kann ok
vielleicht hier mache ich jetzt meine
kurze pause und lest was nach und geht
dann zum nächsten thema über ja richtig
genau genau und wirklich also ich saß in
meinem büro da und habe das abspielen
lassen und habe das besprochen also
wirklich ganz simpel gut an zusätzlich
zu dieser vorlesung habe ich und das ist
vielleicht auch so ein bisschen gerne
fiction habe ich noch ein paar videos
dessen youtube videos angehängt wo es um
die grundlagen der tumor an genese gegen
und weitere signal rezeptoren
das ist einfach das was so ein bisschen
animiert ist wohl einfach noch mal ein
bisschen plastischer mit ein bisschen
mehr action wirklich gezeigt wird wie
die gefäße sich da bilden und wie dieser
signalweg stattfindet das sind auch
sachen die die studenten echt immer
gerne anschauen und da aber eben auch
wissen mitnehmen aber ganz klar ist
bioware after scamming fiction ich habe
jetzt schon ein paar mal gesagt videos
ist also learning ist nordost video
sondern sie müssen es ja nicht nur
anschauen sondern sie müssen es auch
verinnerlichen und grundvoraussetzung
ist dass sie in dieser e learning phase
wirklich da das wissen mitnehmen denn
das wird in der
in der präsenzphase nicht mehr
wiederholt das heißt für den studenten
um zu für ihn selbst zu wissen hab ich
denn das jetzt verstanden
tatsächlich ist es ganz wichtig dass er
den lerninhalt überprüft und das macht
man in der regel über ein quiz und ich
habe es tatsächlich diese sehr rot
fashion art und weise das multiple
choice quiz fragen bei moodle beim
modell verwendet habe da zehn
verschiedene fragen gestellt und jakub
die ich gleich noch mal drauf das ist
eigentlich noch viel viel cleverer und
bessere sachen gibt diese fragen das
waren manchmal transferfragen manchmal
waren des wissens tragen was ganz
wichtig ist dass die nacht bei der
beantwortung der frage und direktes
feedback bekommen haben und da war es
mir auch ganz wichtig dieses feedback
irgendwie somit zum augenzwinkern zu
machen und ein bisschen nett zu machen
was ich will sagt okay mach dir nichts
draus besitzen eine wissens frage aber
merkt ihr das und dass das ist jetzt das
allerwichtigste ja also dass man nicht
nur dass ein student nicht nur sie
ich habe die frage falsch sondern auch
ein bisschen erklärung warum ist die
frage fällt oder was wäre richtig oder
was ist jetzt wichtig märkte nur das
albert ihr vielleicht das andere nicht
der test ist beliebig durchführbar
gewesen
das heißt ich kann mir das video einmal
anschauen und kann den test machen und
nabu
da ist aber noch ein bisschen platz nach
oben also schaue ich mir jetzt video
nochmal ein paar mal mehrfach an
ich habe sogar zu den studenten gesagt
wenn sie den test machen und mit 100
prozent bestehen brauchen sie die videos
gar nicht anschauen ja tatsächlich auch
aufgrund der neugier haben die die
studenten die videos alle angeschaut und
die tests sind in einem jahr ich weiß
nicht mehr wie viele studenten es waren
aber in dem ersten jahr habe ist der
test insgesamt 1000 mal gelaufen also
die haben das wirklich noch und nöcher
gemacht und vielleicht haben sie auch
den test genutzt um damit zu lernen
was mir eben auch ganz wichtig waren das
habe ich ganz direkt in studenten
kommuniziert ist dass der test natürlich
nicht in die bewertung mit einfließen
dass ich mir das noch nicht mehr
anschauen weil es geht wirklich darum
den test zur ein selbstüberprüfung zu
machen und nicht nicht dass das
irgendwie angst haben jetzt mal was
falsches zu klicken sondern dieses war
für die wirklich als als übung gedacht
genau meinte bitter ist wissen wir alle
ist wirklich keine gute prüfungsfragen
art und weise wissen ab zu früher prüfen
was ist bei moodle noch gibt es gibt die
drag and drop fragen das ist aber auch
nicht wahnsinnig viel besser
mittlerweile gibt es in video quiz
fragen und soweit ich weiß ist es
dynamic multiple choice was viel besser
ist als der normale malte preuß weil ich
damit richtig und mit falsch antworten
kann weil ich nur eine antwort bekomme
und die an die antworten konsekutiv
kommen das ist meines wissens geplant
dass es ein modell implementiert wird am
oder vielleicht ist da auch schon so das
kann sein dass ich gar nicht so
abzudecken
ok genau das heißt im prinzip war es so
dass der student zunächst zu hause sehe
ich das wissen angeeignet hat das er
dann den test gemacht hat und je nachdem
wie ihr abgeschnitten hat ist er eben
noch mal zurück gegangen und hat sich
die sache angeschaut
zum teil haben sie sich eben auch in
gruppen und getroffen haben sagt warum
ist es richtig warum ist es falsch und
haben eigentlich alle den test so lange
gemacht bis ihnen wirklich gut bestanden
haben
was für sie selbst eine evaluierung war
habe ich das denn jetzt tatsächlich
bestanden verstanden oder habe ich nicht
verstanden
das war die online phase in der online
phase war es dann so dass im prinzip die
studenten das grundlagenwissen fühlt er
sich sonst immer eine halbe stunde
gebraucht haben sich angeeignet und in
der präsenzphase konnten wir dann
problemorientierte spezialwissen
vermitteln und das habe ich einmal
gemacht dass ich noch mal wirklich
tatsächlich ein bisschen tiefer in die
materie eingestiegen bin aber dann vor
allen dingen haben wir den transfer des
wissens auf aktuelle fragestellungen
also das klassische problem based
learning gemacht und das ist das weshalb
ich tatsächlich philip glass um so toll
finde weil es mir so viel zeit von
diesem stück ihnen stupiden wissens
vermitteln die auch uns keinen spaß
macht ja ich meine diese grundlagen die
jahr für jahr spüren wir die ab vor den
studenten ja das macht uns ja auch
keinen spaß was uns wirklich spaß macht
ist die interaktion mit den studenten
und mit dem zu arbeiten und denen
wirklich irgendwie was beizubringen was
sie in der praxis brauchen und dafür
habe ich eben dann in der face to face
also in der präsenzphase viel mehr zeit
dh ich habe dir eine frage gestellt
komme ich gleich darauf die sie dann die
sie dann bearbeitet haben auch in
gruppenarbeit und ich konnte dann vor
allen dingen während sie in der
gruppenarbeit gearbeitet hat zu jedem
einzelnen hingehen und wie ein coach im
prinzip ihnen sagen hat denkmal in die
richtung oder denkmal in die andere
richtung
genau das war dann die frage also es
ging um um tumortherapie und was ich
einfach gemacht habe ich habe hier sehr
aktiv so viel wissen über wie tumore
funktionieren wie man sie hemmen kann
ihr wisst ein bisschen was welche welche
therapeutischer es gibt jetzt bitte
entwickelt doch mal entweder eine
therapie und welche signalwege kenntnis
und begründet es und so weiter und was
er hier auch ganz wichtig war sind auch
wie hier waren wieder alle hilfsmittel
erlaubt das heißt sie konnten auch
wieder in die in die online phase gehen
und das war das war das was dann auch
den studenten unheimlich viel spaß
gemacht hat nämlich wirklich das wissen
was sie vorher sich angeeignet haben
wirklich zu transferieren
gut die haben die studenten des
aufgenommen dass ich habe jetzt extra
also nach der nach den vorlesungen hole
ich mir in der regel ein zimmer feedback
ein über bingo
das bedeutet ich habe dann einmal fragen
die die vorgegeben sind und dann aber
auch frei formulierte fragen und ich
habe jetzt hier danke schön ich habe
jetzt hier die
extra das feedback von dem ersten
inverters class um den ich gemacht habe
mitgebracht als als themen war also klar
einer hat immer was zu meckern der sagt
immer es war viel zu viel arbeit und der
hat wahrscheinlich bei der was würden
sie verbessern auch gesagt einfach nicht
machen aber trotzdem hat das großteil
der studenten hat wirklich gesagt dass
die grundlagen wirklich gut wiederholt
waren und dass sie eben das blieb mehr
zeit um um die mechanismen und fragen zu
stellen ja und ein paar leute haben auch
gesagt philip glass und bitte nicht in
der prüfungszeit und da komme ich gleich
darauf an denn das ist tatsächlich mehr
aufwand nicht nur für den dozenten
sondern ein hauptsächlich für den
studenten was aber natürlich ganz schön
dass wenn wenn wenn studenten wirklich
mit dem feedback kommen noch mehr frage
und antwort spiel wäre wäre toll und
dann sagt einem nein das war super
schule ähnliches system zwingt ein vor
der vorlesung das skript anzuschauen
weil man dann in der diskussion auch was
sagen kann ja und das ist wirklich das
wo wir dann mit der philip glass rum
oftmals auch ein bisschen kompetenz fürs
lernen auf den studenten übertragen ist
das skript das lehrkonzept wirklich
zielführend
also mehraufwand für die studenten ist
da deswegen würde ich immer sagen
wohldosiert einsetzen vielleicht nicht
in der prüfungs periode mehraufwand für
den dozenten fand ich jetzt wirklich
recht recht minimal also die dem
beitrittsfrage mir zusammen zu stellen
deshalb glaube ich am meisten arbeit
gemacht
was aber ganz tolles man gewinnt
wertvolle zeit für diese face to face
interaktion mit den lernen um dann
wirklich die interessanten frage stellen
mit denen durchzuarbeiten
man hat zeit für gruppenarbeit kann dann
das wissen vertiefen und auch ein
transfer von wissen in den studenten
induzieren sozusagen und das ist auch
das was in der klausur tatsächlich
messbar ist und was ich vorhin eben auch
schon gesagt hat der der dozent nimmt er
die rolle des code und kann deswegen auf
die diversität der studenten eingeben
ganz klar wie es immer bei e learning
ist ein großer vorteil ist natürlich
auch für die studenten selbstbestimmtes
arbeiten sie können sich einteilen wann
sie das machen sie können sich ein teil
mit welchem medium das machen sie
könnten nichts rein theoretisch auch
wieder mit buch
aneignen sie können die länge der
lerneinheit lang bestimmen und was ich
eben auch ganz schönes für eine wenn man
wenn die studenten wieder ein bisschen
mehr verantwortung für das eigene wissen
haben dass sie dann auch tatsächlich
oftmals mehr nach links und rechts
schauen und oftmals auch mehr in die
tiefe des stoffes einsteigen
ganz klar für den studenten das hier
auswendiglernen keine option mehr hat
denn das thema muss echt aktiv
erarbeitet werden und deswegen und die
studenten müssen die probleme probleme
eben eigenständig lösen weil niemand
ihnen die die die lösung vorgibt und das
finde ich eigentlich das was was für
mich am meisten weg dass man wirklich
die verantwortung für die wissens
erlangung wieder mehr auf den studenten
überträgt und deswegen auch auch
tatsächlich studierte zufriedenere
studenten hat ja das war das konzept was
ich gemacht habe mit relativ wenig
aufwand und bei den spenden ist relativ
gut angekommen und ich sage ihnen
einfach mir macht es viel mehr spaß mit
den studenten zu diskutieren als einfach
nur stupide wissen zu vermitteln
vielen dank